[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
c'est parti pour 30 minutes de
décryptage de l'actualité
dans cette émission direction les
pays-bas depuis plusieurs années l'état
ferment une à une ses prisons voir les
revend à de grands groupes qui en font
des hôtels de luxe les alternatives à
l'emprisonnement là bas sont légion
notamment les tiges les travaux
d'intérêt général alors peut-on
généraliser cet exemple reportages et
débats tout à l'heure mais d'abord
l'actualité un sommet européen des chefs
d'état s'est tenue il ya quelques jours
ici à bruxelles
une rencontre qui a fixé les grandes
lignes des élections européennes prévues
en mai 2019 consultation citoyenne
listes transnationales budget européen
n'est talent et l'oiseau ministre
française des affaires européennes est
notre invité mais d'abord donald de tout
ce qui est revenue sur les conclusions
des chefs d'état sur la procédure dite
du speed seule candidate n 'ont
l'écoutent en déchets of legends gates
sur la question des candidats têtes de
listes appelé les jeunes candidats
tonnes il est convenu que le conseil
européen ne peut pas garantir par avance
qu'il proposera une de ses têtes de
listes pour le poste de président de la
commission européenne
cette procédure n'est pas
automatiquement match était une des
sports le traité est très claire cela
relève de la compétence autonome du
conseil européen de désigner le candidat
en prenant en compte le résultat des
élections européennes et après avoir
tenu les consultations appropriées quand
sa tâche
bonjour nathalie d'oiseaux bonjour merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation dont
vous êtes ministre des affaires
européennes alors donald de tout ce
qu'on entendait à l'instant a fait
savoir à la fin du sommet informel des
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement que ceux
ci ne souhaitait revenir sur l'idée de
ce qu'on appelle de manière peu clair le
pixon candidats tonnes c'est à dire que
la tête de liste du parti arrivé en tête
au parlement européen devient président
de la commission ça a été le cas pour
jean claude juncker qui était tête de
liste du parti populaire européen en
elle c'est à dire que les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement revienne sur cet
acquis démocratiques
alors est-ce un acquis démocratique en
tout cas les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ne peuvent pas restreindre
le pouvoir qui leur est donné par les
traités qu'est ce que les traités
demande au conseil européen c'est de
choisir le président de la commission en
tenant compte du résultat des élections
européennes
c'est ce qui s'est toujours passé est ce
que ça veut dire prendre la tête de
liste du parti arrivé premier première
question est ce que le parti arrivé en
première position est capable d'avoir
une majorité
aujourd'hui on est dans un paysage
politique européen assez éclatée où il
n'est pas rare qu'il y ait besoin d'eux
pour tuer des coalitions
ensuite comment est-ce que cette tête de
liste du parti arrivé en premier est
désigné par le parti
est-ce que c'est au travers d'une
primaire est ce que cette primaire est
ouverte
rien ne le dit je ne suis pas sûr qu'on
soit véritablement dans le progrès
démocratique
j'aurais trouvé qu'on aurait progressé
si on avait choisi de faire en sorte que
les listes transnationales désigne de
manière transparente et ouverte des
chefs de file et que cela soit les
candidats à la présidence de la
commission
ça n'a pas été le cas quelle sera la
position de en marché des manuels macron
sur cette élection qui s'annonce donc en
mai 2010 neuf est ce que il est question
que en marche met en place un petit peu
la même dynamique que celle des
élections présidentielles et tente un
système un peu trans partisan et crée
son propre groupe au parlement
prenons les choses dans l'ordre en
marche va présenter une liste qui sera
sans doute une liste plus large que en
marche seul en tout cas en marche va
porter un projet pro européens comme
emmanuel macron la porter à l'élection
présidentielle dans la même lignée se
joindront ceux qui auront envie de se
joindre
et ça c'est au niveau français ensuite
en vue d y les centristes les
constructif potentiel je parle pas
d'étiquette partisane viendront sur la
liste les personnes qui ont envie d'être
député européen de l'être vraiment et
pas simplement de se faire élire
pour je dirais se mettre au chaud à
strasbourg comme ça parfois été le cas
dans certains partis dans le passé mais
qui porte un projet une ambition pour
l'europe qui est partagé avec la
majorité présente hier emmanuel macron
souhaitait qu'on mette en place des
listes transnationales pour les
européennes de 2019
le parlement européen a retoqué cette
idée lors de ce dernier sommet ça a été
un petit peu repoussé aux calendes
grecques tout du moins aux élections de
2024 est ce que ce n'est pas un échec
pour le président de la république alors
c'était pas une idée du président seul
c'était une idée d'une dizaine d'états
membres en particulier tous les états
méditerranéens mais aussi un pays comme
l'irlande était favorable c'était
d'ailleurs au départ une idée du
parlement européen lui-même qu'il avait
déjà évoquée dans le passé
cette idée n'a pas séduit lé parlement
européen cette année pour une diversité
de raison vraisemblablement à ses
partisanes
ceci étant pour nous la question reste
sur la table
il est vrai qu'un certain nombre de pays
n'aurait pas été prêt pour changer leurs
législations nationales d'ici aux
élections de 2010 9
nous allons continuer à en discuter
essayer de convaincre
nous pensons que c'est un véritable
progrès démocratique de faire en sorte
que ces élections européennes pour des
vrais débats européens à 27 est pas 27
débats nationaux parallèles qui ont pour
seul point commun de se tenir n'aime pas
le même jour mais la même semaine
alors plusieurs pays ont par ailleurs
accepté le principe qui était aussi
porté par le président de la république
des conventions démocratiques qui sont
devenus entre temps les consultations
citoyennes
vous allez présenté incessamment sous
peu au conseil des ministres
26 pays ont d'ores et déjà accepté de
participer hors hongrie et bien entendu
hors royaume uni qui va bientôt sortir
alors en quoi cela va consister la télé
loiseau il ya un consensus fort
aujourd'hui à travers l'europe qu'il
faut réformer l'europe que on porte une
ambition européenne forte que la plupart
des grands enjeux aujourd'hui ont une
dimension européenne avec le
fonctionnement
européenne tel qu'on le connaît une
arête une réforme une refondation en
profondeur
l'erreur consisterait à penser cette
refondation qui est destiné aux citoyens
européens sans les citoyens européens à
le faire en chambre dans l'antre soit
sans qu' on est écouté entendu les
attentes
les inquiétudes et les propositions de
nos concitoyens l'idée c'est donc tous
ensemble au même moment de faire en
sorte que l'on puisse débattre sur les
politiques européennes partout en europe
en commençant début avril en terminant
fin octobre
de telle sorte qu'il y ait des débats à
travers les territoires qui transcende
les différentes tranches d'âge les
différentes catégories
socioprofessionnelles que l'europe ne
soit pas un sujet réservé aux plus
convaincus ou à ceux qui font commerce
de détester de critiquer l'europe matin
midi et soir
et à partir de ces propositions donc de
ses remontées de ces restitutions de ces
débats comment peut-on assurer que ces
conventions démocratique où ces
consultations citoyennes seront
respectés à terme par les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement qui seront présentés
les résultats donc en décembre 2018
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire de tout ça
alors ce que nous proposons à ceux qui
vont organiser ces consultations
citoyennes collectivités locales
chambres de commerce chambre
d'agriculture chambre des métiers
organisations syndicales entreprises
universités associations
nous espérons que les organisateurs
soient les plus divers possibles et les
plus représentatives de la diversité est
clair ça veut dire que chacun de
s'emparer de ces thématiques qu'elle
peut créer en fait ça qu'au lancement ce
que nous proposons c'est une charte
simple facile à comprendre pour faire en
sorte à la fois que la démarche soit
pluraliste transparente c'est bien le
moins et que le compte rendu des
discussions des remarques et des
propositions soit rendu public et nous
soit transmis ce que nous ferons c'est
que à l'issue 20 octobre début novembre
on organisera une restitution nationale
pour que ceux qui ont porté sous ces
projets puissent débattre ensemble
puissent lister leurs remarques et leurs
propositions
et l'ensemble de cette restitution sera
transmise au conseil européen de la fin
de l'année pour que les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement qui réfléchissent à
l'avenir de l'union européenne le fasse
en étant pleinement éclairé des attentes
et des propositions des citoyens
européens
donc on doit potentiellement se dire que
certaines de ces propositions seront
aussi présentés dans le cadre des
élections européennes
alors comme l'ensemble du processus a
vocation à être transparent et j'ai
d'ailleurs fait en sorte qu'un comité de
surveillance entièrement trans partisan
soit monté en france pour que tous les
partis politiques puissent voir comment
les consultations citoyennes sont
organisées et ce qu'elles produisent
leurs résultats de ces consultations
citoyennes seront à la disposition de
l'ensemble des partis qui présenteront
des candidats aux élections européennes
on ne pourra pas dire qu'on ne sait pas
ce qu'attendent les citoyens européens
on ne pourra pas non plus à leur place
se dresser en tant que représentant du
peuple sans les avoir écoutés d'abord
alors nous sommes en plein salon
international de l'agriculture
on a beaucoup parlé budget et jean
claude juncker donc il est longuement
revenue lors de la conférence de presse
qui a suivi ce sommet européen informel
de la semaine dernière êtes vous prêts
le gouvernement français manuel macro
êtes vous prêt à sacrifier la politique
agricole commune pour financer ses
autres priorités que sont la politique
de défense ou la politique migratoire
alors ce serait absurde et totalement
contraire à notre vision des choses que
d'opposer les agriculteurs et les
chercheurs ou bien la politique avec
commune et l'europe de la défense ça
n'est absolument pas notre vision nous -
encore que d'autres dans la mesure où
la france est un peu l'un des inventeurs
de la politique agricole commune et que
nous y sommes très attachés
la souveraineté alimentaire de l'europe
c'est un atout extraordinaire la
compétitivité à l'export des filières
agricoles
c'est un des points forts de l'union
européenne il est donc indispensable de
maintenir mais aussi de réformer cette
politique agricole commune peut pour
faire en sorte que l arme mieux nos
agriculteurs en particulier quand ils
sont confrontés à des crises la
politique agricole commune doit être
plus efficaces mais aussi pour faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent mieux structurer
leurs filières être moins vulnérables
et puis les aider à aller vers une
transformation écologique qui est
souhaité par tous mais c'est bien aussi
on parle bien d'une baisse du budget
global de la politique agricole commune
quand jean claude juncker dit qu'entre
la politique de cohésion et
l'agriculture qui pèse aujourd'hui 70%
du budget européen on doit arriver à
réduire ces polices et ses politiques
on est assez clair ah mais c'est lui qui
le dit ça n'est pas ce que ce n'est pas
la position française est pas la
position française
nous portons une ambition forte pour
l'europe ça veut dire qu'il faut un
budget lui aussi ambitieux pour répondre
aux attentes de nos concitoyens sur les
politiques de repères c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on fait des consultations
citoyennes
au moment où nous allons négocier le
futur budget c'est-à-dire les futures
priorités d'action de l'union européenne
il vaut mieux le faire autrement que
dans la bulle de bruxelles en écoutant
ce que les européens nous demande sur le
budget européen on entend dire également
que vous seriez prêt au niveau européen
et le conditionner notamment pour
certains pays de l'est qui ne respectent
pas toutes les valeurs européennes ont
pensé à la pologne on pense à la hongrie
on pense plus globalement aux pays dits
de devises grade
il faut être très clair l'union
européenne ce n'est pas simplement un
marché unique et ça n'est pas simplement
un carnet de chèques
l'union européenne c'est un
rassemblement de pays qui partagent des
valeurs parmi ces valeurs
l'état de droit la séparation des
pouvoirs l'indépendance de la justice le
respect de l'indépendance des médias
la solidarité est elle ne s'exerce pas
dans un seul sens et pour une seule
raison il faut
être cohérent l'union européenne c'est
un projet les fonds européens doivent
servir à soutenir ce projet pas en
sortir mais il faudrait pour ça engagé à
chaque fois des procédures de sanction
pas nécessairement mais on peut aussi
conditionné le versement de fonds au
respect des valeurs de l'union sans
changer les traités ça paraît la moins
sans changer les traités
bon dernière question on attend cette
semaine la validation ou non d'un accord
de gouvernement en allemagne angela
merkel a proposé quelques noms pour le
ministère ce week-end et nos voisins
italiens sont appelés aux urnes
également ce dimanche
est ce qu'il ya un risque de voir la
droite et l'extrême droite revenir au
pouvoir en italie
est ce qu'il y a plus globalement un
risque de blocage institutionnel au
niveau européen quand on voit emmanuel
macron portée des réformes mais
finalement être assez esseulé face à ces
mises en oeuvre puisque nos voisins sont
pour l'instant dans des blocages
institutionnels en des blocages
politiques
alors je suis très confiante que
l'allemagne aura prochainement un
gouvernement un gouvernement pro
européen puisque le contrat de coalition
entre la cdu et ses sous et le spd
comporte un chapitre sur l'europe
substantielle et qui est extrêmement
proche de la manière dont nous voyons la
réforme de l'europe à l'heure actuelle
en italie nous travaillons dans
d'excellentes conditions avec le
gouvernement italien actuel nous ne
pouvons que souhaiter que le prochain
gouvernement italien poursuivre dans
cette voie pro européenne qui est
l'intérêt d'italie l'intérêt des
italiens nous avons déjà commencé à
faire bouger l'europe et ça n'est pas
emmanuel macron seul face à une inertie
européenne sur beaucoup de sujets
l'europe de la défense par exemple on a
avancé
ap alger ans alors qu'on avait pas pu
faire de progrès pendant des décennies
il ya je crois une conscience partagée
par tous à travers l'union européenne
que notre destin commun mérite que nous
nous engagions davantage et que nous
soyons plus ambitieux pour l'europe donc
à vous entendre il serait plutôt
bienvenu que cette continuité ne fasse
pas arrivé une coalition entre l'extrême
droite et la droite en italie au pouvoir
ont coûté la montée de l'extrême droite
n'est une bonne nouvelle nulle part
n'oublions pas qu'en france et le
maquereau à affronter une candidate
d'extrême droite au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle donc nous
donnons de leçon à personne mais nous
avons tout intérêt ensemble à ce que les
pro européens ambitieux et lucide puisse
faire avancer ce beau projet qu'est
l'union européenne merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci voilà
donc pour cet entretien enregistré un
peu plus tôt direction maintenant les
pays-bas depuis plusieurs années la
justice là bas favorisent des peines
alternatives à la prison notamment les
tiges les travaux d'intérêt général
résultat les prisons se vident ferme
voire sont vendus par l'état avant d'en
parler avec nathalie griesbeck m'ont
invité reportage de samia de gier
[Musique]
à 200 kilomètres au sud d'amsterdam le
centre-ville de ruraux monde abrite un
hôtel très particulier
bienvenue au rsa reste suisse un
établissement de luxe aux allures
d'alcatraz sexy pendant longtemps de
1863 à 2007
ici c'était une prison puis de 2007 à
le bâtiment est resté vide c'est à ce
moment là qu'on a fait les plans de
l'hôtel après deux ans de travaux à 8
millions d'euros
le bâtiment est transformé en hôtel pour
séjourner ici compter en moyenne 150
euros la nuit pour deux personnes dans
l'un des cachots confort ou suite du
prisonnier le standing n'a plus rien à
voir avec celui des anciennes cellules
mais les traces du passé pénitentiaire
sont soigneusement conservés pour
attirer les touristes en quête de
sensations comme vous pouvez le voir il
reste encore une bonne partie du
bâtiment d'origine les escaliers sont
d'époque et porte aussi ses portes n'ont
pas vraiment d'utilité et on les a
laissés pour que ça ressemble à une
cellule on a aussi gardé les barreaux
ici et dans presque toutes les chambres
aux morts à homs
la vente de ce bâtiment a rapporté 1,5
million d'euros à l'état néerlandais
en tout cette prison comme celles ci ont
déjà été vendus aux pays-bas des prisons
devenu inutile faute de prisonniers pour
les remplir
les pays bas comptent moins de soixante
détenus pour cent mille habitants
l'un des taux les plus bas d'europe
pourtant il ya une vingtaine d'années le
pays comptait deux fois plus de
prisonniers
la plupart condamnés à des courtes
peines des séjours de quelques semaines
derrière les barreaux qui n'était pas
vraiment à faire baisser la criminalité
quoi tu as fait la conviction qui domine
chez les chercheurs mais aussi dans le
monde politique
c'est que les peines de prison de 3 mois
maximum non pas vraiment beaucoup de
sens elles sont trop courtes pour avoir
un effet et en plus elle coûte très cher
alors le gouvernement a dit il faut
qu'on se tourne vers des peines qui ont
plus de sens 5,6 pour désengorger les
prisons
le gouvernement a donc choisi de passer
par une réforme pénale
les peines de moins de 3 mois peuvent
être remplacés par des sanctions
alternatives
beaucoup de petits délinquants sont
désormais placée sous liberté surveillée
ou condamnés à des travaux d'intérêt
général
à notre avis ça va du ménage dans une
maison de retraite au jardinage au
nettoyage des graffitis dans la rue un
outil apprécié des juges
les peines alternatives concerne
aujourd'hui près d'un quart des
condamnés ils ont deux fois moins de
chances de récidiver qu'une personne
passer par la case prison avec une peine
de travaux d'intérêt général
la personne va être en contact avec un
milieu professionnel
elle va à travailler arrivé à l'heure le
matin et faire le travail qu'on va lui
demander
du coup les condamnés vont apprendre à
se sociabiliser
alors que souvent quand les gens sont en
prison ils perdent leur travail leur
maison leur logement et quand ils sont
libérés une fois leur peine purgée la
tentation de récidiver est grande
en dix ans le nombre de détenus a été
divisé par deux ils sont désormais moins
de 10 milles derrière les barreaux vider
les prisons n'a pas seulement permis de
lutter contre la récidive
l'état néerlandais a aussi gagné
beaucoup d'argent 104 millions d'euros
en tout pour la vente de cette prison il
ne compte pas s'arrêter là
plus de vingt maisons d'arrêt vont être
vendus dans les prochaines années
[Musique]
alors quelques semaines après les
manifestations de surveillants de prison
en france et à l'heure où la belgique
loup justement aux pays-bas des places
de prisons peut-on suivre l'exemple
néerlandais est ce que celui ci peut
être généralisé je pose la question à
nathalie griesbeck bonjour bienvenue à
vous vous êtes député modem donc membre
du groupe libéral démocrate ici au
parlement repères vous êtes membre de la
commission libertés civiles et
présidente de la commission spéciale
terrorisme qu'est ce que cela vous
inspire cet exemple néerlandais le fait
de permettre en fait des alternatives à
l'emprisonnement est ce que cela
pourrait être un exemple à suivre
reposer donc ces peines alternatives
c'est quelque chose de très intéressant
et en plus bon l'exemple et très concret
puisque bon il où effectivement des
places au gouvernement belge pour
organiser son système carcéral
ils vendent les prisons donc au lieu que
ça coûte très très cher
ils ont des réponses qui sont
intéressants dollar ce qui est
intéressant aussi qui est très bien dit
et auquel on devrait s'atteler parce que
les bonnes pratiques il faut s'en servir
pour essayer de répondre par exemple
dans notre pays la france qui est
particulièrement en difficulté
rien n'a été fait pendant des années on
a laissé les choses traîner c'est que ça
diminue très fortement la récidive on
voit que la france là dessus a quand
même énormément de progrès à faire
avec près de soixante sept mille détenus
pour 27000 28 mille agents c'est des
chiffres eurostat la france a un ratio
de 2,39 détenus par surveillant qui la
classe parmi les plus mauvais élèves de
l'europe elle a été condamné plusieurs
fois pour manquement à la dignité
humaine et traitements dégradants par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait un espèce de
plan orsec si je puis dire des prisons
en france de la politique carcérale
oui il faut des moyens aussi il faut une
volonté politique moi j'ai le sentiment
que emmanuel macron le chef d'état a a
conscience de l'ampleur des travaux qui
doivent être menées sans doute créer de
nouvelles places de prison c'est ce qui
a été décidé conforter aussi
en termes de ressources humaines la
position des surveillants de prison qui
sont les accueillant pas très bien payé
1 à la fois puis qui sont soumis à une
violence justement lié à l'absence
d'espoir pour une part des détenus et au
niveau européen qu'est ce que vous
portez ici au sein du parlement vous
notamment au sein de la commission
spéciale terrorisme que vous présidez
il ya aussi question qui est
particulière de cette députée
radicaliser radicaliser et on l'a vu
dans le cadre justement de des
manifestations des gardiens de prison
cela était une de leurs revendications
ils disent ne pas être en mesure de
prendre en charge ces publics
cette partie là elle a bien été entendu
je crois par le gouvernement et par le
chef de l'état il faut avoir un
traitement spécifique pour les personnes
radicaliser il ya plusieurs écoles on
les regroupe tous ont les disséminer tu
sais moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
regarder de près et à nouveau voir les
exemples ailleurs parce que les
disséminer c'est aussi un risque de
dissémination du discours de haine et de
la radicalisation ans mais une chose est
sûre et ça je crois que c'est bien
compris c'est qu'il doit y avoir un
traitement spécifique pour les personnes
radicaliser et je crois que ça ça a été
entendu au plan gouvernemental
vous disiez au plan européen voilà sur
la partie responsabilités président de
la commission de lutte contre le
terrorisme mais sur la partie commission
travaux de la commission liberté justice
affaires intérieures le parlement
européen n'a pas compétence et une
fonction régalienne des états bien se
faire mais ya eu un excellent rapport
qui a été produit je crois à l'automne
2010 7 octobre 2017 de la part de notre
commission qui a été très bien adoptés
qui travaille justement ces peines
alternatives qui travaillent la lutte
contre la récidive qui donne un certain
nombre de pistes à partir des bonnes
pratiques là l'exemple est très
intéressant parce que ce sujet c'est un
sujet sensible s'il est spéculée les
auditeurs où les spectateurs suivent
cette émission il y en a quand même
beaucoup qui sont pour la répression à
100% mais en fait je le redis
je pense que plus on construit de places
de prison plus elles sont remplies donc
il faut le faire à bon escient
proportionnellement par rapport aux gens
qui ont des peines longues parce qu'ils
ont commis des crimes et qui doivent
purger leur peine
et pour ceux qui ont des sanctions plus
légère la détention le bracelet
l'alternative l'hébergement mais la
surveillance la liberté surveillée
finalement ce terme si on l'entend bien
il est important de pour permettre
qu'une fois la peine purgée
et puis ce sont les réactions sinon
sinon oui on se tire dans une spirale
alors c'est l'heure du checkpoint
nathalie griesbeck cette semaine en
brasse carton se penche sur une
déclaration d'eric coquerel députés
français la france insoumise qui affirme
que le parlement européen est une
institution fictive sans pouvoir alors
le checkpoint s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
les pouvoirs du parlement européen le
parlement européen ne sert à rien il y
prend aucune décision importante pour
l'union européenne
c'est ce qu'affirme sur twitter le
député de la france insoumise eric
coquerel
le parlement européen est fictif il n'a
quasiment aucun pouvoir
alors à quoi sert vraiment le parlement
européen avec ses 750 et un député c'est
un des principaux lieux de débats au
sein de l'union c'est là qu'on discute
et votent les lois européennes le
parlement dispose de trois pouvoirs
principaux un rôle législatif la
commission européenne sort de
gouvernement de l'union propose des lois
le texte est discuté par le parlement
puis par le conseil de l'union
européenne
ils passent de l'un à l'autre avant
d'être approuvés modifier ou rejeter un
rôle de surveillance c'est le parlement
qui élit le président de la commission
européenne
il a même le pouvoir de faire
démissionner cette commission enfin un
rôle budgétaire le parlement établit le
budget de l'union
là encore il partage cette compétence
avec le conseil de l'union européenne
mais dans tous les cas c'est vrai seule
la commission européenne peut soumettre
des propositions de loi au parlement en
jargon européen en appelle ça le
monopole d'initiative ce privilège de la
commission n'est pas à sens unique
le parlement a le droit de demander à la
commission de faire une proposition de
loi
mais la commission n'est pas obligé
d'accepter cela veut-il dire pour autant
que le parlement ne sert jamais à rien
remontons le temps jusqu'en 2004 cette
année là le futur président de la
commission josé manuel barroso veut
prendre l'italien rocco buttiglione dans
son équipe
problème le candidat a tenu des propos
homophobes
les eurodéputés s'oppose donc à sa
nomination finalement c'est un autre
italien franco frattini qui obtient le
poste
bref la commission reste bien aux
commandes dans de nombreux domaines le
dire que le parlement européen n'a
quasiment aucun poids plutôt faux c'est
plutôt faux nathalie griesbeck qu'est ce
que vous avez à répondre de ce genre d'
attaques contre votre institution pas
deux choses en surface la première chose
c'est que certains collègues dans les
parlements dans le parlement français à
l'assemblée sont vraiment friand
d'essayer de faire des mots et de faire
de la communication du buzz c'est comme
si je disais l'assemblée nationale ne
sert à rien c'est tout c'est
complètement c'est juste pour faire de
la mousse et la deuxième chose rigolote
aussi que je me permets de dire c'est
que ce serait bien que ce collègue à y
voir monsieur mélenchon qui était quand
même longtemps ici ouais c'est pas l'air
de s'y plaire avant de terminer cette
émission bien entendu une pensée pour
notre confrère slovaque jan kuciak
journaliste d'investigation assassiné à
27 ans il ya quelques jours avec sa
compagne d'une balle dans la tête dans
leur maison près de bratislava il
enquêtait sur des cas de corruption et
de fraude fiscale qui impliquerait des
personnalités politiques et la mafia
italienne
robert fico le premier ministre slovaque
a offert 1 million d'euros de récompense
à qui fournirait des informations qui
conduirait à l'arrestation des assassins
ce meurtre on s'en souvient intervient
quatre mois après la mort dans les mêmes
circonstances de daphné karuna gallizia
à malte
merci beaucoup nathalie griesbeck
d'avoir été non c'est ok voilà c'est
fini pour cette semaine mais vous
retrouvez bien entendu la semaine
prochaine ahmed tazir ici à bruxelles en
attendant on se retrouve sur le net
britney et sur les réseaux sociaux très
belle semaine at his ciao
[Musique]